la viruela del mono es una enfermedad
rara los síntomas incluyen una erupción
costras además de fiebre dolores
musculares ganglios linfáticos
inflamados escalofríos y agotamiento se
han registrado decenas de casos en
varios países europeos desde portugal y
españa- hasta suecia y reino unido se
trata de una enfermedad grave pero no
altamente infecciosa para los humanos
bing xing la cepa que se está viendo en
el actual brote en europa es la cepa de
áfrica occidental que tiene una tasa de
mortalidad de aproximadamente 1 de cada
100 wang en sangre el departamento de
salud pública de massachusetts dice que
ha confirmado un caso en un hombre que
viajó recientemente a canadá
este paciente está ingresado en nuestro
programa especial de patógenos
actualmente se encuentra en condiciones
estables facebook inversión en el
paciente se encuentra bien con seguridad
en aislamiento en nuestra unidad
actualmente no hay cura para la viruela
del mono está estrechamente relacionada
con la viruela que fue erradicada hace
décadas la vacuna contra la viruela
puede dar cierta protección
para anderson y realmente necesitamos
entender mejor el alcance de la viruela
del mono en países endémicos como la
república democrática del congo y
nigeria la república centroafricana y
otros para entender realmente cuánto
está circulando y el riesgo que supone
para las personas que viven allí así
como el riesgo de exportación los casos
recientes en el reino unido- se
produjeron predominantemente entre
hombres que tienen relaciones sexuales
con hombres todavía no se ha determinado
si el inusual aumento de casos fuera de
áfrica indica un cambio en el virus o en
los medios de propagación